t
50 % dans Parc-Extension.
DAVIDE GENTILE
- Ici, la majorité des patients
parlent une des langues
du sous-continent indien.
Cette clinique est
un concentré de la diversité
de Parc-Extension, où
les immigrants forment
la moitié de la population.
MANPREET LABANA, gestionnaire,
Clinique Parc-X
- Ni anglais, ni francais,
seulement punjabi, un peu hindi.
- Le district est l'un
des deux plus pauvres au Québec.
En plus, l'accès à un médecin
de famille est l'un des plus
mauvais de la province.
Dr JHANZAIB SHERWANI,
omnipraticien, Clinique Parc-X
- On est à peu près 35 000
personnes ici à Parc-Extension.
Moi, je dirais, le taux
de prise en charge, c'est
à peu près 50 %.
- Dans Parc-Extension,
environ la moitié des citoyens
n'auraient pas de médecin
de famille, encore pire que
dans la région administrative
dont fait partie ce quartier.
Depuis 2018, le pourcentage
de citoyens qui ont un médecin
de famille a même baissé
à 60,9 %. Pourtant, l'objectif
de Québec était d'atteindre
85 %, mais le taux, même
à l'échelle provinciale,
a aussi légèrement baissé,
à 8à 8à 8à 80,1 %.
Cette clinique compte
seulement sur l'équivalent
de deux médecins à temps plein..
- Moi, je dirais, pour
vraiment... donner le soutien
à cet arrondissement-là,
on a besoin entre 10 et 15,
temps plein. Alors, ouais.
- De plus?
- De plus.
- Il faudrait au moins
dix médecins de plus dans
Parc-Extension, qui peine
déjà à en recruter.
ANDRÉS FONTECILLA, député, QS,
r-Dorion
- Les permis de pratique pour...
qui pourraient venir à Parc-Ex
sont détournés. Les médecins
préfèrent aller travail
ailleurs. Donc, voilà.
Il y a une compétition.
- La compétition vient
d'endroits plus attirants ouplue
de répartition. Par exemple,
Ville Mont-Royal, Outremont
ou même Côte-des-Neiges,
qui compte plusipitaux.
FRANCINE DUPUIS, p.-d. g. adj.,
CIUSSS du Centre-Ouest
- C'est comme un patchwork
de sous-territoires. Certainsbùs
veulent pratiquer, et ce
quartier-là, qui est une enclave
vraiment très particulière,
dans notre territoire, ou
on ne réussit pas à attirer
les médecins.
olution serait d'octroyer
des permis de pratique médicale
exigeant que les médecins
restent trois ans exclusivement
dans Parc-Extension. C'est
qui a été fait avec un certain
succès dans le quartier
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve.
Une idée proposée pour Parc-Extr
Québec.
- Ils ont déposé la demande
au ministère et malheureusement
on a eu une fin de non-recevoir.
C'est assez regrettable,
parce que ça cristallise
un peu la situation marginale
de ce
- Une situation marginale
qui risque de perdurer.
L'île de Montréal a obtenu
30 médecins de moins que prévu
pour l'an prochain.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, M